oh we want to talk to Benji or no oh
sure
you're on your own on this one Howard
you're on your own on this one we did a
test last night and Benji you know
everyone's video comes up and Benji was
the only one who looked ah he look like
he's in a mining disaster because he's
on his back as well yeah cuz Benji
injured his leg hilarious yes
you could sit up her tomorrow I'm gonna
get to you tomorrow
no okay I'll get to you tomorrow he
started to [ __ ] cry cuz he's not
getting airtime powered yesterday when
we were doing the test
I said Benji can you set up and he goes
I have to figure it out what you don't
know you can sit up or not by the way he
injured his leg what why can't he sit up
on a couch yeah what's his leg got to do
with sitting up yes yes sir serve an
operation but it was I believe it was
now three weeks ago it was on his leg
and we're not asking him to walk we're
just asking him to sit up all right
before we get off this thing let's limit
him to one question thank you God you
stood up and then he gives us the answer
and then i alright Benji why is it why
yesterday during the test couldn't you
sit up because the surgeon says it's
dick it's dangerous to sit up all the
way at this point does anyone believe
that no me neither
hey that's the first time he's actually
answered a question though so that's
good yeah there's one more thing about
Benji Benji is against all of the
regulations that have come out to try to
stem the coronavirus oh do you want to
hear that I think Jimmy needs to hear
this ng is it true you're against people
being shut down and businesses no that's
what I said was
there should be a process that other
that like a due process to it where
there is a limit to how much Cuomo can
shut it down that other people have to
approve it like maybe you can say it's
this is an emergency we have to do it
for ten days but then the legislature
has to approve it I just want more of a
bus no more people to die in that
process no Robert I said he could do it
immediately
like the president declaring war thank
you okay let's uh Benjie I'll get to you
tomorrow and he wants more red tape
that's good absolutely
then she wants to go through a huge
process we'll all be dead by the time
the processes of
you